spiders are amazing we've learned this
mainly from observation from comparing
webs body shapes and seeing the
outrageous adaptations of spiders in
action now close reads of spider genomes
are showing that we don't know the half
of it looking back through time to see
how spiders have evolved has been
especially difficult fossil evidence has
shown us early ancestors but the speed
of their evolution has confounded
scientists starting in 2014 two
different teams use genomics to compare
hundreds of genes from 40 spiders they
found that some orb weavers web making
spiders are more genetically similar to
web less spiders than the rest of the
orb-weaving group this suggests that web
weaving must have evolved twice or much
earlier in a common ancestor a later
study comparing 3,400 active genes and
70 species indicated that web --less
ground-dwelling spiders such as jumping
spiders diversified much faster than the
web Weaver's the silk genes are where
the true complexity of spider genomes
comes into focus all spiders can make
silk and they use it for many things
webs trapping prey egg casings transport
and more silk genes have been difficult
to characterize because they code for
very large proteins with highly
repetitive regions but genome reads of
silk glands are showing there are a lot
more silk genes than previously thought
take the golden orb weaver genome it
codes for 28 silk genes and eight of
them were unknown before the genome of
cobweb weaving spiders revealed a
whopping 209 potential silk and glue
components these findings may help
bioengineers harness silks remarkable
strength and flexibility to make
artificial silk understanding spider
venom has been daunting because it can
involve a cocktail of up to 1,000
different chemicals and the mixture
varies from one spider to the next
scientists have made progress in Carrick
rising black widow spider venom but
getting a genome sequence has proven
difficult instead they turned to the
genome of its relative the common house
spider 47 toxins known as lateral toxins
were found in common house by der Benham
even though these spiders aren't known
to have painful bites this venom
cocktail is different than the black
widows which includes a toxin called
alpha lateral toxin that does attack
vertebrate cells this may have arisen so
that black widows couldn't snare prey
with back bones like lizards curiously
the house spiders lacked Roe toxin genes
match up best with a bacterial gene so
researchers think a microbes gene
somehow got transferred into the
ancestor of both the house and black
widow spider these new spider venom
findings will help scientists refine the
search for new drugs and therapies the
complexity of the few spider genomes
that have been sequenced indicate many
challenges ahead but as this data
becomes available to scientists the web
of spider discoveries will continue to
grow
[Music]